okay my friends that was Muhammad Ali
his life his legacy now let's close it
up a few more points that I want to
highlight I'm gonna go ahead and take it
to a clip of some pastors I know this is
very sensitive now but I want to drive a
point home of the double standard the
hypocrisy let's go to it and then I'll
give you my thoughts afterwards but at
Sacramento's Verity Baptist Church
Pastor Roger Jimenez told his
churchgoers what have you asked me hey
are you sad that 50 pedophiles were
killed today no I think that's great
III think that helps society you know I
think Orlando Florida is a little safer
tonight now that 50 you know the tragedy
is that more women die I mean the
tragedy is I'm kind of upset that even
finish the job everybody Pastor Steven
Anderson here from faithful Word Baptist
Church in Tempe Arizona and I just
wanted to record a quick video about the
news this morning about the shooting in
Orlando I guess a Muslim terrorist went
into a gay bar and shot him up and
there's 50 sodomites homosexuals that
have been killed and another 50 some-odd
injured and then the the Muslim guy
himself was was shot by the police it
sounds like and here's the good news and
the bad news about this you know the
good news is that there's 50 less
pedophiles in this world because you
know these homosexuals are a bunch of
disgusting perverts and pedophiles
that's who was a victim here are a bunch
of just disgusting homosexuals at a gay
bar okay and then I'm sure it's also
going to be used to push an agenda
against so-called hate speech so Bible
believing Christian preachers who preach
what the Bible actually says about
homosexuality that it's vile that it's
disgusting that they're reprobates you
know we're gonna be blamed like oh it's
it's it's all extremism it's not just
the Muslims it's the Christians do you
have any regrets about your statements
during your sermon on Sunday I don't
have any regrets about what I said and I
don't take anything back I would never
take things into my own hands have
become a vigilante but I will say this
you know the Bible says that homosexuals
should be
to death in Leviticus 20:13 now the
question is what if these were Muslims
we got to be fair all across the board
if you're a journalist if you're in the
media if you are someone out there who
has a social a civil responsibility
let's take a lesson from Muhammad Ali he
stood on truth he stood on solid ground
and at the end what he came out
victorious he was blacklisted probably
considered an enemy of the state at that
time just like Martin Luther King
Malcolm X but now you have days holidays
named after him he's an American Muslim
hero Muhammad Ali so stand for truth
report the truth don't go ahead and
twist the truth let's go to another
example you know this gentleman James
whole why nobody talking about him
this guy plotted and was planning with
weapons and chemicals to make a bomb he
was on his way to blow up a parade why
nobody mentioned in him his religion is
not mentioned nothing these guys these
sociopaths mentally disturbed people
they end up doing something and you look
nothing's mentioned about his religion
they're happy whole entire segments to
look into the history of his life what
kind of childhood he had you don't think
we have also in a community of over 1.6
billion you got people who are also not
functioning properly up here they're a
product of their environment you have
what's glorified nowadays violence and
the music in the movies why don't we get
together and try to change and make a
difference here I mean you don't have
someone who's an American and someone
does these mass shooting now every
American has to go when he's overseas in
Germany wherever else he's traveling he
has to go ahead and apologize for all
the American criminals that are out
there does he what about somebody shares
the same name as you never met this
person he just has the same last name
Maxwell whatever the case did you have
to apologize with this person named
Maxwell who carries your same last name
him not even related to you you have to
apologize for him why then with Islam
why then was in Salaam why the double
standard because it's an agenda
Paul you see Islam is under attack we
know that that's a fact but the fiction
is that Islam is a threat Muslims are a
threat if anyone sincerely looks at the
data looks at the reports looks at the
statistics this is a boogeyman has been
created a false narrative that's being
perpetuated and pushed you as a sincere
individual who's seeking to know the
truth you will see that you have more of
a chance of being killed by a toddler
with a gun or by your furniture this
whole myth that's been created that now
wall-to-wall coverage Islamic radical
terrorists this is something that is
far-fetched and beyond its hype you have
more of a threat from functioning
organizations you know there's almost
like 200 KKK organizations function
these people if they had their reign
they be lynching massacring killing and
you have other organizations right-wing
zealots that are out there and you don't
hear much of this at all we talked about
Hiroshima on the lights where this guy
was planning to with a met weapon of
mass destruction to reign havoc in a
society very little news coverage but
anyone with a Muslim name sat with a
Muslim had any connection to a Muslim in
Islam you see what's happening wide
range spectrum all over the news so much
hype and you know what it's to promote a
political agenda create fear and when
you have that fear people give up their
rights certain agendas get pushed and
you you've just been bamboozled
that's it here's the point let me close
it up you know just in him Chicago my
hometown we just had 40 I just had a
mass shooting at least is seven killed
according to authorities and some 46
others injured in shootings over the
weekend not call us at this number if
you still if you have some questions
some queries you have some doubts 1 800
662
upper a ters are standing by
if you have some apprehensions some
questions some doubts some
misunderstandings that's what we're here
for make the human connection don't be
on the side of hate be on the side of
understanding of love creating a
connection between us because we are not
going anywhere my brothers and sisters
we're here and we need to work to get to
know our neighbors instead of hating our
neighbors just like the Christians are
here the Muslims are here and the others
are here we have to work together in
unison we have to work together to make
the world that we live in as a better
place as Muhammad Ali said that's the
rent that you pay back to God for being
spending time on his earth is to make
this world a better place for all thank
you very much for tuning in we hope that
you enjoyed this week's episode we'll
see you next time until then peace be
with you
Salaam alaikum you don't want to miss
out you want to be here every Friday and
then we'll try to give you some short
reminders in between but you can't get
that if you're not coming back to the
show every week
Fridays will be releasing it God willing
inshallah subscribe right now and enjoy
all of the content that we're going to
be putting out for you thank you peace
be with you
so Mike